LG: I'm Larry Goldstein, I'm a professor of cellular and molecular medicine
at UC San Diego, and I'm pleased to be here interviewing Paul Berg
in a second segment, about Paul's experiences both originally
in the regulation of recombinant DNA as you heard
in the previous segment, and now I want to move him along
to discussions of places where the original model of recombinant DNA
has not worked as well, where the issues have perhaps
been a little more socially complicated. Paul, you'll remember,
is a Nobel Laureate, a winner of the Public Policy Award
of the American Society for Cell Biology, and in some ways a role model
that many of us have sought to emulate in our dealings with
the body politic and the press and everything else, so Paul
thank you for joining us again. PB: Thank you. LG: So thinking about
Asilomar and how Asilomar and recombinant DNA regulation
really set the tone for scientists calling for regulation
and driving the kind of regulation that has in fact developed
and been followed. I know that genetically modified foods and the stem cell
debates have not lent themselves very well to that kind of model.
Are there principles you think or reasons why that has not worked so well
in this context? PB: Yes, so let me go back a little bit. The scientists
did not call for regulation. The Asilomar meeting was actually the
attempt to bring out the various views and various constituencies
and to try to assess, was there or was there not a risk.
The assessment was, it was some risk, but we could mitigate those risks
by having these guidelines. So the guidelines were a recommendation
of how to proceed. Now if you look at some of the other issues
that have confronted science and public policy, the one that
came shortly thereafter was genetically modified foods.
And the question was, there's lots of data that says it's safe
and there's lots of public policy that doesn't want to have it in their backyard.
Would an Asilomar-type meeting help to bring together these
two opposing views and try to draw some kind of consensus
and the answer that we found was, they were almost irreconcilable views
and the views on the opposition were mostly cultural.
They weren't questioning the science in large part. And in the main
in Europe particularly, it was the desire to try and maintain the traditional
type of agriculture. So we just never could get the two sides to mesh
LG: Even on safety issues? Cause I know the opponents often claim
that there are safety problems. PB: Right, so the companies set up trials,
they did all kinds of, the FDA approved many of these things after examining
the data. There was always the problem of the dissemination of weeds
that would take hold. All these kinds of things arose and slowly but surely,
the scientific data dispelled almost all of them, but never could challenge
people at the core values of their culture. What they felt about food,
what food meant to them. And in many ways one of the problems
I think early on, and the agriculture business recognized it is, all the genetic
modifications they were making were to facilitate better yields for the farmers,
make work easier for the farmers. The public would say, well what do
I get out of it? I'm taking the risk of eating something that you tell me is safe,
but may turn out not to be safe in the long run. So why should I take
that risk when all it's doing is making the farmers' job easier and richer.
LG: So was this a case, maybe, of the scientific community not finding
the right way to explain or the right message or the right way to reach people?
PB: Well, I'm not sure what kind of message you could do, cause it's,
we'll get to in a moment...LG: Well you can tell people that it would make
food less expensive for them or more nutritious. PB: All of those arguments
were made. All of those... LG: And they didn't work? PB: No. And my own view
thought, ultimately a shoppers going to walk into a market and see two bins
and there's the bin that was genetically modified and there's the wild type
and the price is going to be half for the genetically modified
and they are going to have to make a choice, and the pocketbook
again will be... LG: Free markets sometimes correct these things.
PB: Now, the issue of culture is the same thing with the stem cell issue.
So I don't how many meetings when the embryonic stem cell issue arose,
there was the violent opposition coming from essentially
the cultural right wing, but religious organizations, and then people
who themselves felt deeply about the sanctity of life and the anti-abortion
constituency. So everything was opposed to the embryonic stem cell work.
I don't know how many meetings I attended, where these
two constituencies met, and it was like talking by each other.
Talking right past each other, you could not persuade those who felt
deeply and conscientiously about sanctity of life, that you couldn't
convince them that this little blastocyst was not a definition of life.
And that is not so well understood when people want to say,
well let's have a conference and bring these two opposing views together.
They have to be views that are willing to listen to each other, and
that there is some give-and-take as there was in the recombinant DNA
and that some of these other things there is no middle ground.
LG: Well of course, with embryonic stem cells, Congress got into the act very quickly
in this case didn't they? PB: Yes. LG: So you testified I know in a
number of hearings in the Senate. Were you in one of the first ones?
PB: I was, I don't know, in any number of them, yes, and what you could see,
what was being played out was this cultural, religious perspective
against the scientific opportunities. And it was easy for that other side to
pooh-pooh the scientific opportunities, and in fact say, well you haven't
done it yet. And you'd argue, well we can't do it yet, because you won't
allow us to do it. I think if I look back on that whole period of
the scientific community coming together, at least California, and being
able to get embryonic stem cell work approved, making the case to the public
and getting an almost overwhelming approval, is another example
where the scientific community used its reputation for, and I'm going to go
back and say Asilomar set a tone. Learn to trust the scientists.
My engagement in that public policy debate wasn't as rewarding as
the recombinant DNA was, but I'll tell you, I'm just going to admit to something
which I have admitted to a number of people, during that entire debate
I along with most of us said adult stem cells were never going to be useful.
We have to rely on embryonic stem cells. And I think today there's
more work going on, and more interesting things going on with adult stem cells.
LG: Well there's terrific work going on with both, right? PB: With both.
But I think what I found is dismissing the utility of adult stem cells,
but in fact more and more of them are being cultured and propagated
and maintained and in terms of the debate about embryo versus
adult, I think the most immediate benefits are going to come out of either
adult somatic stem cells from various tissues, or from the iPS cells
the cells that were adult cells that have been converted
to embryonic-like cells. And I think the debate was good to have,
and in the end I think we have progress, which is important.
LG: There's good science happening, which is what really matters on all fronts.
PB: Now just to take the lesson from Asilomar one step further,
are there going to be other problems that are going to arise?
LG: Well that is what I was going to ask you. I mean looking forward
doesn't all new technology bring new ethical challenges? PB: More and more
the big one that is going on now is synthetic biology. Now you can make
organisms, make anything, and I have defended that and actually
have been involved with things, and I am a strong advocate, but there are
people saying, "Yes, but...", and the "Yes, but..." is what are the nasty
things you can do with the same technology, and I think we are going
to have to work through that, so the government again has set up a
very strong panel to oversee the developments of synthetic biology
and several interesting things have developed. So for example,
these commercial places that will make DNA for you, now have a rigorous
protocol that they have to examine. A request to make a particular
DNA sequence. They have to translate it and see what it in fact will,
what kind of protein it will make. Who's going to use it. There's a lot of things
before they will actually make it and approve it. So the idea that some
weirdo is going to send in a request for some nasty toxins...
LG: small pox or whatever is always the nightmare scenario...
PB: is unlikely to be done.
But nevertheless, synthetic biology is confronting an issue of creating
microbes that will be making biofuels, and I'm absolutely
astonished and amazed about what people are actually doing.
I mean Craig Venter is making whole chromosomes, Jay Keasling is
turning out organisms that are using biomass, the organism programmed
to actually digest cellulases and xyluloses and convert them into sugar
internally and make long chain fatty acids that are being used to drive trucks.
LG: So you sound very optimistic that we can both solve the technical
as well as the safety concerns there. PB: I think the genome project has
provided an extraordinary library of information of genes
LG: From not just humans, but from all organisms. PB: All organisms.
So if you go to an organism, the sweet wormwood plant, and take out three genes
and put them in E. coli so they make now artemisinin.
LG: What the heck is artemisinin PB: Artemisinin is the major drug
now being used for treatment of drug resistant malaria.
And so it's a very complicated
molecule, and so it's costly to synthesize with the usual procedures.
Isolating it from the plant is very complicated. So Jay pulled out the three genes
that carry out the last three steps of the synthesis of artemisinin,
engineered the steroid pathway of E. coli. So you make a precursor
and with the three enzymes from the wormwood plant they pour out
artemisinin and now big plant manufacturing it on a commercial scale.
LG: So you make an anti-malaria drug in an E. coli fermenter. Incredible.
PB: And that is now making kerosenes, making airplane fuels.
LG: So in retrospect you took an enormous leap when you walked out of the lab
and decided to spend some time working with the public.
Is that a good model going forward? Do we need more of that? Do we need
less of it? What are your thoughts about that? PB: Well there are people
who can do this. Who are articulate and persuasive and could play a role,
and there are those that can't and won't. And I think we have to encourage
people because, after all, this is our world, the scientific community is
and what we do is our world. And if we don't defend it, in one way, explain it
then we are not doing half the job. We publish papers
as a way of communicating what we've done, LG: To each other.
PB: But the general public doesn't read these papers and they are in the dark.
And you are using mumbo-jumbo to describe what you do.
And so there are people who are very skilled and enjoy actually explaining
what they do in more general terms to the general public
and that's a very valuable thing for those people to do it. I think we have to
clear the path so it's not sacrificing ones career. LG: Yeah, I mean
if one were to make the argument to some people and say, well
you can only do it after you've gotten the Nobel Prize, which means it's
a very small population. PB: Well, okay, it doesn't have to be a Nobel Prize,
it could be when your career has gelled to the point where you're now
recognized so that in fact if you are going to make statements
people will say it is coming from authoritative source. LG: Build some respect.
PB: Younger people sometimes say, nuh-uh I don't want to get involved in that
I'm in science to do experiments, but when you grow up, okay,
and it is when you grow up and you feel assured of a modicum of success
that you can go out and do this, and you have to do it conscientiously
and seriously and honestly. LG: And you have to bring rigorous science.
PB: And you have to bring rigorous science. LG: Thank you. PB: Good.